it might even be if you want to talk
about it
kind of mystically or spiritually that
that
we can somehow sense this thing being
born around us and that's part of the
confusion of the moment yeah something
else is in control at this point and it
isn't really us anymore these systems
have outrun us you know the the machine
is much bigger than us
and to some degree it's starting to not
need us as much as we thought it did
[Music]
this is jonathan pedro
welcome to the symbolic world
i mean obviously following your
newsletter
just overjoyed uh getting it every time
and so
i was hoping that we could talk a little
bit about your project right now and
what you're doing because i think when
we talked last time you hadn't yet
started
um yeah i think i was just kind of yeah
thought maybe just starting maybe yeah i
think i was just starting off but i
wasn't sure where it was going to go but
it's kind of yeah still not quite sure
where it's going but
i more or less know but yeah it's uh
it's been it's been really interesting
actually
and you know the world has changed so
much like we just said exactly in a year
it's like it's like trying to half the
challenge is just keeping up with what
the hell is going on
yeah yeah and doing it
talk about current affairs much
and
staying in touch with knowing what's
going on and then not letting it not
totally suck you into yeah that's that's
the big challenge yeah i mean i i think
uh you're very wise not to engage in
current affairs very much on your
channel actually it's the way it's the
way to do it you have to just keep that
same distance from it you know
yeah i'm trying it's i i was a little
more involved with what was going on
here with the you know because i felt
like it was more grounded like i had my
feet on the ground i had a sense of what
was going on and the consequences of the
decisions of the government in terms of
the covet actions and stuff so i felt
like i was that it was fine to be more
involved a little more active in that i
even went to the the trucker
participated twice in the trucker
protest all right okay yeah how was it i
was really following that
it was very really interesting and weird
what was going on there it was
astounding i mean it was astounding
because it really
revealed the disjoint between the
narrative and what was actually
happening i mean you go you went there
it was amazing and
not only was it amazing but you could
find hours and hours of people streaming
you know you can go online on youtube
and find people walking around the
protest for five hours at a time every
day and so you can know what was
actually going on
but nonetheless it didn't matter in
terms of the narrative and so it was
astounding it's a great revelation isn't
it so maybe it's one of the things we
could talk about but it was the same
with brexit in britain you know exactly
the same
that was supposedly a fascist uprising
and then you actually went to see what
was going on and funnily enough it was
nothing of the kind exactly it's the
same narrative it's just rolled out you
know yeah
all right so
you got to be the testing ground there
didn't you for the uh for the new bios
bio state
that's what it that's definitely what it
feels like it's strange to think that
canada is somehow
uh
let's say the the center of anything in
terms of narrative but it seems like it
just happened also because our prime
minister is so
sold to the whole thing like he's just
so completely sold and we should have
known i mean he's been saying things for
10 years that
for since he's been you know in politics
he's been saying the same thing
and you know that what what he's saying
what it means you know when you when he
says something like
we are the first post-national nation
yeah and when you hear it at first
you're thinking oh you know he he
doesn't want nationalism he doesn't want
that i understand that but then when you
you realize oh what it means in terms of
globalism you think okay so that's what
that means
yeah
yeah hiding in plain sight
exactly that's what it feels like so
yeah
all right so i mean um i think that if
you're okay i'm actually already
recording i think we could just keep
going people know who you are everybody
knows i think by now uh who paul king's
north is let me introduce you paul
kingsworthy is a writer
and uh we i had him on my channel before
he's written several novels but recently
he's been writing a wonderful sub stack
that i keep telling people subscribe to
paul's sub stack because he looks at the
situation with a a piercing insight he
doesn't give in to extremes but he is
also
has a has a very keen look on what is
going on what it means for us as
as humans what it means for us as as
christians as people living in this this
world trying to kind of find our place
and make sense and so i was hoping that
we could talk about that a little bit
what your
recent project is you know also
get a sense of what it's been
attracting to you because i imagine all
of a sudden your horizon of people that
are contacting you that are
you know discussing with you has has
changed in the past few months and so i
would really like to to get a sense of
that so maybe we could start with that
and you can tell us
what was the impetus behind these this
this sub stack and what you know what is
it that's kind of driving you as you're
writing these
articles yeah well it's always
it's always a challenge for a writer to
know what's driving him but really for
the past 25 years i suppose
since i started writing i've been
writing
pretty much about the same thing even
though i didn't necessarily
know it consciously and that that that's
true of my fiction and my non-fiction as
well actually and the thing i am writing
about is
the manifestation of this
uh
giant system of
control technological system of control
state control corporate control
and all the rest of the manifestation of
that versus the kind of human scale way
of life that maybe is is more
traditional but also is is still very
excellent in large parts of the world
and i started off writing that
writing about that as a young kind of
environmental activist i suppose very
much a man of the left not that i've
ever liked putting myself into boxes but
you know my first book was a kind of
very much a kind of idealistic young
man's anti-globalization tract and i
spent a long time
traveling the world and and visiting
communities that were kind of resisting
corporate capitalism and the spread of
this thing and i've really spent as i
said the last 25 years writing about
that from different perspectives and in
different ways
um and i suppose my politics have
changed a little bit although actually
fundamentally i still believe the same
things i did when i was 19.
um
but what i've seen what i've come to see
is i suppose a much broader perspective
of what's going on
um and over just over the last couple of
years
um with what happened with uh with the
coveted pandemic in the way that that
was dealt with now what's going on in
the ukraine and and more broadly than
that actually just the the
the kind of very very rapid rollout of
this technological society very
interconnected very technological very
uh very much openly now monitoring
people and controlling people and
shutting people down if they don't have
the correct perspective it's become very
much clearer that the thing that i've
been writing about for a long time
is
is manifesting very kind of publicly
everywhere now you know whatever you
think of say a vaccine passport system
whether you think that's a good or a bad
idea that's very clearly something that
could not have happened even five or ten
years ago the technology wasn't
available the ability to do it wasn't
available similarly with say shutting
russia out of the global financial
system again whether or not you think
that's good or a bad thing it's now a
possible thing
um whether whatever you think of what
your government did in canada with the
truckers protest and the ability to
remove people from the financial system
if they don't like
the government's uh actions again that's
a that's a thing that is now happening
in a way that it hasn't been happening
at least in the west
before and so
this sub stack i'm writing is really
just kind of a way of
well firstly i i i just write to get
things out of my head otherwise i'm
going to go mad i mean that's funny
fundamentally certainly in non-fiction
terms i mean fiction is much more
creative and enjoyable but non-fiction
you're trying to work out what the
hell's going on
so i'm really trying to
outline this thing that i i've called
the machine which is a term that was
coined by greater writers than me in the
past from dh lawrence to george orwell
to just describe this
almost impossible to pin down but very
obvious manifestation of technological
control that's been growing for hundreds
of years but is now accelerating and i'm
trying to work out what it is what it
means what the alternatives are to it if
there are any
um and also somebody who's who's a
christian um but quite a new christian
i'm trying to to understand what that
means in the context of
the christian faith and more broadly
what's
the spiritual perspective on it because
increasingly it's obvious to me that
this is actually a spiritual crisis more
than anything else so so yeah that's
quite a lot to be going on with isn't it
no but i think it's wonderful and i felt
that it's been very complementary to the
things that i've been talking about in
terms of
the notion of the the system of the
beast let's say i've used i kind of use
apocalyptic terms which i i guess scares
people because people think i'm always
saying it's the end of the world which
who knows maybe it is but that's really
not the point it's mostly about
showing that in scripture there is a
pattern that that relates directly to
the notion of technology and control and
which begins with the idea of the mark
of cain
uh writing is actually part of this this
technological system and it moves into
the city of kane into weapons into
civilization itself which contains in it
you could say something like the seed of
cain
it means that civilization isn't all bad
but it never that necessarily has an
aspect of it which is about
the problem of inclusion and exclusion
and the problem of of controlling your
borders and controlling you know uh what
is inside and giving yourself power in
order to do that it's an inevitable part
it's kind of an inevitable part of
civilization but one which has a very
dark
aspect and as technical
capacity grows we always see it as an
increase in power which it is of course
it's an increase in power
but that means that those that wield
political power are always
always their powers increasing as
technical capacity is increasing as well
and so as we so i actually frame it as a
i frame it as both the machine in terms
of control but also it's it's like
balance with a weird anarchism it's as
if there's on the one hand this sense
that you should be completely free to do
to be to to do whatever you want that
there's no limit on you and your
identity and whatever you want to be but
that in order for that to that narrative
to be possible there's a counter
narrative which is always growing with
it which is
that you always have to be completely
safe and complete everything has to be
safe and
in in a very very uh
secure secured area so that you can
experiment all that craziness because
obviously in the normal traditional
world
right you can't just be whatever you
want because you'll die of hunger right
you're just not going to eat you won't
you have to stay connected to other
people in the community in order for for
the community for you to exist but in
this world it's like it's a vacillation
between i'm a completely idiosyncratic
being that does whatever they want and
you know has can express myself in
whatever manner i want but at the same
time i live
at the same time in a world that is
completely controlling me and setting
down you know
uh limits that if you cross them at this
point right you're you're excluded in
ways that would not have been
possible before when money becomes
digital
you know i can't i won't be able to you
know i won't be able to unless we
actually start bartering again which
might actually happen at some point but
if money is digital unless i have hide
you know a chicken hiding
i can't i won't be able to participate
in the financial system i won't be able
to buy i won't be able to sell so
yeah well i've got i've got a load of
chickens outside and they lay a lot of
eggs so you're too far away to share
them with unfortunately but at least
but
that's something but it's um
civil civilization as a control system
has always been a control system and all
civilizations from rome to babylon as
you mentioned obviously are control
systems and this one is the most
effective and the most global and the
most technologically advanced and so it
means that the things that
uh the babylonian kings or the pharaohs
might have liked to do to control their
population are now possible um and if
you have a system that is this
centralized and which is this dependent
on say global supply chains and is this
dependent on technology and there's also
this dependent on growth because a
capitalist economic system requires
endless growth and in order to keep that
going um it's necessary to to
you know do all sorts of things for
managing population numbers to managing
industrial output to managing trade you
can't allow any of the balls to drop to
the floor otherwise the whole thing
potentially falls apart so
the
need and the desire for control just
grows and grows and grows and yet at the
same time as you say you have this kind
of on the one hand extreme coercion and
on the other hand kind of extreme
liberalism or or
or individualism in which on the one
hand
yeah we can be anything we want
literally anything we can imagine we can
redefine our own bodies if we if we feel
like we've just done that
but at the same time if you cross any of
the kind of red lines that are drawn by
the by the culture then then you're dead
meat and and you could literally be you
can have your bank account taken away
and this is happening to people
um and so you've got this sort of
strange combination of extreme
liberalism and extreme illiberalism at
the same time and it's it messes with
the head actually i mean you talk about
um
you know different people writing to me
but maybe the common
i mean i have people from right across
the spect from writing to me all the
time and
a lot of the common maybe the common
factor that people will often come out
with is i just have no idea what the
hell is going on
and and people tell me at least
sometimes that they value what i'm
writing because i'm trying to work that
out and they find it useful to sort of
come along with me but it is just so
immensely confusing because so many of
the things which as you say maybe in a
more customary society
people will just live with family
community local level institutions roots
in a place all of these things that
would define most traditional societies
around the world they've all been
demolished and so we're left with on the
one hand the individual and on the other
hand the increasingly powerful state
which has a kind of corporate arm and a
media arm and that that's almost become
one blob of power corporations the state
and the mass media
and then there's us little people and
depending on where we live in the world
we've got more or less
of a kind of rooted community around us
but fundamentally the whole the whole
thing is reduced to a binary of you know
powerful state up here and the little
person down here and so that's how you
get this weird thing in which you can
define your own reality but at the same
time you're more controlled than you've
ever been and it's extremely confusing
and it and it's kind of rushing in that
direction all the time
and um the other thing to think about is
just the huge
uh wave of imagery that we're battered
with all the time the the possibility
now through social media and the web to
just give us
endless images i mean the war in ukraine
is a great example of this has ever has
any war ever been kind of so
relentlessly covered and live streamed
you know you can get this diet of
horrible
you know images and and news and
conflicting ideas and opinions all the
time
and it's almost impossible to you know i
long for the old days where you turned
the bbc on and the man would tell you
what was going on and
that was the news and they'd there'd be
a war reporter and there he was and he
would he would say this is what's
happened here
um and it's yeah so you've got all these
kind of uh these forces coming at your
consciousness from so many different
directions and i think increasingly a
lot of people just find it almost
impossible to to manage it actually just
to navigate the whole system
yeah i mean i think
the way you present it as the two
extremes i think that that's the key is
that
a normal kind of traditional what i call
this kind of symbolic world is a
is a constant negotiation between
levels of existence so you know you
exist in these embedded communities so
you have your
you know you have your friends and your
family and that creates a kind of
cohesion and then that's embedded in
churches or embedded in community groups
embedded in villages and towns and you
know and and ultimately it does reach up
it can reach out very high in terms of
empire in terms of nation but because
you have these buffered realities then
you know at the point where sometimes
the king might become tyrannical you can
find some solace and some protection in
your family or in these more embedded
communities but
because of the way that the system is
getting set up because of the fact that
the state in many of our countries the
state has become the the sole arbiter of
all your existence right it's the it's
the it's this it decides pretty much
everything about you know how you're
going to live your life then you have
these two extremes where the state
becomes more and more powerful the the
the human beings become more and more
disconnected from each other
and uh then
then the the power becomes absolute but
people don't feel it so much i mean uh
until until they do right they don't
feel it until they do if they're like
you said if they're inside then they're
okay and they feel like they can do
whatever they want they can watch
whatever netflix show they want they can
you know they can consume as much in any
manner they like but as soon as
sometimes the face of the system
shows itself and i think that that's
something that during kobit it has
you know that something happened for it
was funny like when justin trudeau
basically shut down people's bank
accounts i think that i don't know
exactly what happened we don't know what
happened in the background of that but
it seems like he let the mask slip a
little too much for some people because
all of a sudden
in a week later they they they pulled
back or a week and a half later but i
think they realized that this is telling
people we can do this not only we can do
this we're going to do it we're going to
do it increasingly and and the russia
situation is the same like watching
people in russia get there going to the
store and then using apple pay and it
doesn't work
do you think that that's only going to
be used
outside
that it's not going to be used inside it
was it happened just a month ago in
canada so of course it's going to be
used on you and the short-sightedness is
astonishing i mean i have you know i
have
say friends on on the liberal left my
old activist buddies and i see some of
them out there you know cheering on what
trudeau did because they brought into
the line that this is just a bunch of
fascists who turned up to wave swastikas
and so it's great that he can shut them
down now even if that was true which as
far as i could see it wasn't true at all
but even if it had been true even if it
had been a fascist rally or whatever
are you still really comfortable with
the government doing that do you think
that that won't be used elsewhere do you
do you trust any authority at all to
have that degree of power over anyone
you've got to be very short-sighted to
do that i mean it's interesting looking
at trudeau from where i am because i'm
no no expert on canada but he's you know
he's almost a poster boy for
how to be a liberal isn't he in in in
the global sense you know he said he
said he says all the right things and
yet at the same time
he's just used the most authoritarian
powers in in any modern democracy that i
can that i can see
but people don't under they don't
realize i think it's also there's a
sense in which people are just don't
know history or don't actually totally
understand
seem to not understand how democracy
works or how
systems work and so you know i i always
use an extreme example and i tell people
you know if i if i rape a child they
won't take away my bank account
like if i go out in the street and i
start killing slashing people's throats
they're not going to take away my bank
account
you understand that so
why do you think that it's normal to
take away bank accounts like that's
insane to think that you will actually
cut people out of the capacity to to pay
for and people just thought it was a
normal thing to do and to do it against
your political enemies
that's insane it's like we're reaching
levels that are hard to describe well
that's the thing that's new and it's
it's like this stuff has been normalized
something has happened over the last two
years
where this kind of
firstly society has become incredibly
tribal in the west i mean we already had
this culture war brewing in america
which has come roaring over into europe
as well especially into into britain
um less so where i live in ireland thank
the lord but i'm hoping that will last
but
you already had this culture war after
trump was elected and bricks it happened
in britain there were already all these
divisions opening up and people weren't
listening to each other at all
um but it's it's gone into hyperdrive
over covid because you know the war
against the unvaccinated and the
so-called anti-vaxxers
was astonishing you know i'm not
vaccinated myself so i had to
sit here and uh be excluded from the
life of my society for six months for no
obvious scientific reason at all um but
even if there had been you know even
even if the arguments for that had been
legitimate which in my view they weren't
it was still done without question with
no discussion and with a complete media
blackout on any dissenting views no
conversation
um in some countries obviously it was
worse they had mandatory vaccination in
other places
and it was so normalized that it seems
to me now that
you know wherever you are
on that on
whichever kind of side of this fake
battle that you've decided to put
yourself on
it's increasingly possible for you to
justify extreme measures against the
guys that you've decided the bad ones
and there's this kind of extreme
moralism on the one hand where your
enemies are not just wrong but they're
evil
and and then as we as we were saying
that's coupled with the ability to use
power technological power especially in
a way that hasn't been possible before
and then at the same time you have this
kind of development of the the sort of
the moral state in which the state is
taking
uh
very clear lines on what is acceptable
to say what is not acceptable to say
what are moral positions how you should
behave at work how you should relate to
each other in a way that states have
never really done before at least to
this degree you combine all of that and
we're going into a situation where
people nobody's listening to each other
everybody wants a war or at least a lot
of people do especially the ones on
twitter apparently
social media sites you know social media
sites have so much power and influence
just for basically a bunch of people
sounding off on the internet which is
what they were what they are the ability
of those sites to effectively destroy
people's lives and reputation sometimes
yeah it's astonishing so you've got all
this stuff kind of converging at hyper
speed
and it's quite frightening i don't know
where it ends because it you ask
yourself how could you defuse this
and i don't know how you can diffuse it
in the context of a culture that's
that's disintegrating i think
and an economy that's starting to fall
apart uh with a kind of ecological
background of disintegration as well
it's it's difficult to know
you know there's certainly no returning
to whatever period you thought was
normal put it that way
no it doesn't seem like that's for sure
at this point we're not going back to
anything and people have to stop
thinking it's going to to return you
know two years after the beginning of
kovid most of the countries still have
emergency powers and they keep pushing
back when they're going to let that go
and why would they let that go we let
them have it for two years so i i mean
maybe they will for a little little
moment just to make people feel like
made people feel like they're doing
something but uh you know the track is
set the pattern is has been accepted and
so by now
um
it seems like only a very very large
crisis will be able to
to kind of pull us back from what is
happening and so i don't necessarily
yeah i don't anticipate that with great
joy but it's it seems like it's not
going to it's not going to return
without some
massive
crisis a very big one it will sadly have
to be very big for it to to pull back
and so in the meantime i think
you know i think that rods rodriguez
kind of idea for the benedict option all
of a sudden becomes more and more
salient for us because
there is really nothing else you can do
besides try to
make yourself resilient you know in
terms of human connections
in this in your actual physical space
you know to to create uh alternative
networks
besides the one that are mediated by by
the state and by the banks and by all of
these systems obviously we can't avoid
it we're so trapped we're so caught into
it we can't avoid it but we can at least
be conscious and try to find try to find
other solutions to be more resilient as
this is uh as this is moving forward
yeah and it's interesting that you know
you mentioned the benedict option and
that's again that's a sort of um
it's a variation on things that have
been happening forever almost i mean i i
like the idea of the benefit option but
i was thinking recently that we also
need an anthony option you know people
who are just going to go to the desert
live in caves you know that came first
the desert fathers but you know also you
know you could look back to the look
back to the 60s and the intentional
communities that were created by you
know people broadly i suppose from the
left rather than the conservative
movement or whatever but it's not you
know you could you can look at that
wherever you come from wherever you
place yourself on any spectrum if
they're even real things
um
yeah you can look at the system that's
developing around you and you're going
to have to say to yourself right how can
i best avoid this
way that i can escape it whether that's
a physical escape which it probably has
to be i think increasingly as much as
possible but also
you know spiritual escape and i think
that has to be about
forming communities with others you know
in some way and and being you know even
if there's there's a lot of value in
even just online communities of people
who think the same as you but also
you know practical physical realities of
places where people are gathering
to do things differently um
and uh yeah it's it's interesting that
as i say you can be
you can be from any uh sort of from a
different perspective from different
place on this on the cultural spectrum
but you can see that that's very clear
that that's what's going to have to
happen and that's almost interestingly
it feels like a sort of in invitation to
to recreate real community again in
places i think so exist anymore and
that's you know if you want to look on
the bright side of all this horror we've
been talking about that's what it is you
know it's like okay we've got to this
point where this civilization is so
inhuman and impressive to everyone who
doesn't conform to its increasingly
narrow kind of bandwidth of what you're
allowed to say and do
um you just got to get the hell out you
know you've got to tune in turn on and
drop out as the hippies used to say
you're totally right i felt we we had
the experience here where because of the
measures and because of as the measures
we're moving towards church especially
we're moving towards you know
legislating who can go to church and who
can't go to church
luckily i mean luckily you know by the
grace of god our church passed the
kobe test because for some churches i
think some churches in canada
they'll never get back they'll never get
over what happened because those that
impose the vaccine passport on their own
members and we're forced to have someone
at the door checking you and and knowing
that if you can't pass this test you
have to go go back home um i don't think
those churches are gonna survive i don't
think i mean i think they might kind of
coast for a while but i don't think
they'll ultimately survive
the the their own
spiritual decisions you know but luckily
our parish did and for that
we are much stronger than we were at the
outset of covid and it was so hard you
know we lost our buildings because
nobody wanted to rent to people anymore
and you know it was like this constant
wheel of obstacles but because of it you
know our parish has become stronger and
more deliberate and so i think that
hopefully people can take that as and
the same with like even some friendships
we have
it feels like we became way more
deliberate about our friendships and
about the
connections that we have because we
realize that this is
everything else might be taken away but
this is the most precious thing
yeah no i had a similar experience
actually i mean
luckily the i mean i'm a member of the
romanian church here in ireland and so
you know the orthodox churches here are
quite different i think from uh say the
catholic church partly because they're
immigrant churches and so they they sort
of slightly operate under the radar but
it's you know it's a different
it's a different feel but we didn't have
you know i felt the same that you know
people
at the same time as people weren't
discussing this
in the church at all i mean people
discuss it outside but it wasn't
something that came into the liturgy or
something or into sermons you know
vaccines or whatever people had
different opinions and
who knows but nobody was asking anyone
else who was vaccinated that never
happened i've never seen that nobody you
know nobody cares no one's going to make
that judgment
um
and yeah absolutely you come out of that
with a strong sense of
what's actually real here and who's real
and who who is going to treat you like a
human being you know i've certainly lost
friends over my the writing that i did
about the about facts vaccine mandates
especially a lot of my old lefty friends
they now think i'm i don't know what
they think i am but i'm i'm
perceived right a right-wing conspiracy
theorist of some kind yeah and that's it
i have a right-wing conspiracy theorist
and that's very interesting to me
because as far as i can see i'm saying
the same things i'm saying 25 years ago
on this subject right
aren't you the left aren't you supposed
to be against the state power aren't you
supposed to be suspicious of big farmer
aren't you supposed to be suspicious of
big tech isn't that the whole almost the
entire point of the left how come you've
allied yourself with these guys and i
still cannot work that out i mean the
trajectory of some people on the left
who
are now accusing people who are saying
what they said 10 years ago
of being fascists i mean i cannot get
into my head quite
what shift has been made there but it's
just part of the general weirdness of
the whole situation a lot of the people
who used to
spend their time raging against state
power
are radical authoritarians now they want
the state to clamp down on almost
everything as far as i can see
i've heard people who i used to think
were
anti-capitalist activists arguing for
the state to jail people who aren't
vaccinated it's just it's a rabbit hole
it's a lot of different rabbit holes and
it is almost as if it's
that invitation to to escape from this
is an invitation to get your spiritual
and your practical feet on the ground
again and say okay how can i get some
sanity back here and the more i look at
um say the amish who have a very
critical intelligent relationship to
technology you know which is not just a
a blanket rejection but is also not the
kind of mindless button pressing
acceptance that we have in the west the
more i look at that and i think okay
well they've they've managed to survive
for 400 years yeah something there's
something that works there you know
whether or not you share their
particular
christianity or christianity at all you
can say there's a community that knows
how to how to make itself work
so what are they doing that we could
emulate even if we're coming from
different places and traditions
yeah i've told people i've
always brought up the old order
mennonites and the amish for people who
want to look at real functioning
communities i would think that you know
when you look at all the the communities
that came up in the 60s like all of them
most of them just failed i don't think
if there's any still functional whereas
the mennonite communities are have
hundreds of years of history and like
you said they're approaching technology
people think that they just reject
technology they don't what they do is
they they ask to what extent technology
is going to serve or not the community
that's all the only thing that's what
they ask of the technology so you'll
you'll find different communities come
to different conclusions some will say
oh we'll have one car for the whole
community or a few cars for the whole
community and people will have to you
know share it
and so therefore they no one will be
tempted to have all these the problem
with the car and they're so right
because the car makes you have friends
all your friends can be an hour living
an hour or you know 30 minutes from you
and so you don't have community you just
have friends that you visit like this
and you know i mean that's what that's
where we are that's that's life but
there's a manner in which that is
obviously a problem that we don't we're
not friends with people that are friends
with each other and that have to deal
with the kind of communal
not some of us are but a lot of us don't
have that especially if we live in
suburbs we just have neighbors and then
we have our friends that we visit and
that's really just the car that did that
no no absolutely i mean i kind of cut my
teeth as an environmentalist as a as an
anti-car activist at anti-wrath actually
back in the 90s you know i used to chain
myself to bridges and try and stop roads
being built there was a big movement of
that going on in britain in the 90s and
that was one of the critiques actually
you know it's like this this these
things not only did they trash the
countryside and the towns because you
have to build motorways everywhere but
they're radically isolating you know you
get in your car you put your own music
on you go where you like and that's kind
of you know that's fun it's the kind of
liberation myth of the west you know
it's like james dean and
all the rest of it yeah you call bruce
springsteen get in your car drive where
you like but you know there's a
consequence
uh and there's you know it makes makes
me think there's a there's a
there's a long-standing christian
critique of technology that you'll get
famously in people like say wendell
berry who's been writing about this for
50 years about community and about
technology uh ivan ilitch is another one
jacqueline yeah jacqueline's books are
terrific from a christian perspective
his absolute critique of exactly what
you're talking about the system of
almost the system of the beast but the
system of control and how this is all
rolled out um and nina these guys were
writing half a century ago that wendell
berry's been writing since before i was
born
about this uh and he and he lives it as
well so
this is almost like the ground has been
prepared in a way by a lot of
very smart people who could see this
coming
and it's now here and it's going to
accelerate and so the question is yes
how do you
go and live that and you know the answer
is going to be different for everybody
but it has to be that question is going
to get more urgent every week
yeah a funny story if you it's a funny
and sad story if you want to know how
crazy the world has become
i was asked
i was asked to talk at the jacqueline
society this summer here in mcgill by
some of the prominent members of the
society and i didn't even know what's
going on it caused a massive controversy
and then a massive problem in the
society and it went up all the way to
the president of the society supposedly
because i'm uh supposedly i'm a
notorious anti-vaxxer
and and i thought that's hilarious i
mean i don't even care about the vaccine
i always i've been saying from the
beginning that my issue with this has
very little to do with what they're
injecting into me it has everything to
do with the system of technological
control which is which is in which it is
wrapped and i thought so the jacqueline
society won't let me speak there you
know and they're supposed to be
christian anarchists it's just hilarious
that is quite something i wonder what
jacqueline would actually have thought
of that i think you've had a lot of
things to say about vaccine passports
yeah and but it's exactly exactly that
point i mean the writing that i did
about the
vaccine system was was talked about in
exactly the same way you know this is
anti-vaxx writing which it wasn't i
don't care whether anyone's vaccinated
you should be vaccinated if you want to
be um again it's about the system of
control that is connected with it and
that is something that plenty of
vaccinated people are concerned about
right and this is not an issue of
good vaxxed or bad unbacks or vice versa
but because of this insane tribalism
where people are just looking for an
enemy and not listening to any of the
nuances it's almost as if
as you said earlier um
people aren't really concentrating on
what's going on you know i think because
people a lot of people anyway certainly
in the in
the ones who are really in the political
ideological trenches are so obsessed
with destroying their enemies whoever
they think their enemies are they're not
paying attention to the bigger picture
which is that whoever you are whatever
wing of the spectrum you think you're on
you're going to have to do what this
thing says you're going to have to
conform to this machine and it could
take any number of different shapes
and if you if you if you think that nice
mr trudeau is is using his emergency
power as well and that's all right
because you're a liberal like him
now we'll wait 10 years and see if
canada gets a very right-wing government
which starts using them against you do
you not see that possibility you know of
course anything could happen once once
the system is closed around you which is
one of the points of the jackal all made
endlessly
you know it doesn't matter who you are
you're going to have to be
you're going to have to conform to this
world as saint paul would put it so how
are you going to not conform to the
world and that's a
it's an interesting spiritual question
as well as a practical one you know and
i think that's the root of it because
as you said before actually that a lot
of the sort of
id idealistic communes that were set up
in the 60s most of them collapsed
and jonathan height did some writing
about this a few years ago he quoted a
study on this
and
any community intentional community that
was set up over the last 50 years or so
in the west that survived almost all of
them were religious yeah
so they you know they may or may not
have been christian but people came
together with a higher aim and their
higher rate was to serve god to do
whatever spiritual work they thought
they had to do the ones that fell apart
were the ones where lots of
kind of idealistic individualists came
together to change the world and then
fought each other and then slept with
each other and then the whole that's
right
five minutes but the ones that survived
and still survival today overwhelmingly
have a higher aim they have a spiritual
aid
which is which is a lesson you know
because just having a community in sense
of being in a place
isn't enough unless you think you're
doing something
that is more significant and important
than politics or or anything worldly
actually
so that's that the thing that interests
me now and i don't know the answer to it
is
uh maybe you can answer it for me what's
that what's the i'm hoping so what's you
know what's that what's the for a
christian particularly what's the
spiritual
response that we should have to this i
mean we've talked about sort of benedict
option in a practical sense
you know going to a place and and
forming a community but you know what
was
i'm interested in this one and uh
it's
yeah question how do you live because
you know you can you could do what i've
done to a degree i live on a small
holding out in the country and i have
friends around me who are
similarly kind of uh alternatively
concerned about the the thing the
machine and so we try not to participate
too much and i don't have a smartphone i
don't have a tv
so i'm sort of on the edge of it
um
but you're still in it all the time it's
still all around you you can't not
engage with it so the question is what's
your spiritual work how do you man how
does that manifest in your life i
suppose
yeah
i mean i think i definitely think that
first of all
just being intentional is the first step
in j for most people at least
understanding that that's going on and
now being intentional about your
choices and about the things that you
attend to
you know most of it i think has to do
with hierarchy and but it's hard because
it's hard because these technological
things they they're made to basically
devour your attention they're made to
take it all up but so i don't obviously
i don't think that there's
anything wrong and to a certain extent i
think christians will always have to
somewhat engage with
the system because we're not i don't
think
christians are
unless you're really a monastic and you
but even even even monasteries are never
isolated completely there's always
there's always a sense in which we're
also meant to radiate in the world in
terms of example and in terms of
patterns so i think the best thing would
be to be deliberate and to be
hierarchical in what is your priority
and so make sure that you know your
family
that's the you know your family is a
priority your communities are the
priority create deliberate relationships
with people around you work towards
alternative
systems but
not be
i think i think
being wise about it you know christ said
be you know be innocent as dubs and wise
as as serpents and i think this is right
now
is the time to do that i i made a video
about king david and how king david
escapes the tyranny of saint paul above
saint paul
that's hilarious that i said that of
king saul
because saul becomes paul in his own
story so i get saint paul like that's
the problem of symbolism is when things
connect in your mind too much symbolism
exactly
that makes you say that king david is
escaping saint paul anyways so king
david tries to escape the tyranny of
king saul and and by
doing that he becomes everything of the
margin
he becomes uh he comes he associates
with these debtors and thieves you know
he lives in a cave he pretends to fight
for the enemy of king saul he he feigns
being crazy he does all these things
that are completely you know look like
he's he's a strange uh shifty character
and so i think that we have to start
thinking that way we have to to to not
be naive about things but understand
that we also have to
be shifty at this moment and be able to
be able to navigate with with some
trickery you know the world that is
laying itself in front of us yeah yeah
it's a trickster moment isn't it that's
right
and it's um
there's an issue of uh just trying to be
in the world but not of it which is the
thing i keep coming back to all the time
it's very interesting i've been reading
a lot about the um there's fathers the
early ascetics recently
um and what's interesting about so many
of them so many of the saints who go off
to live in the desert including anthony
himself
um
they go off for a period of time but
then they're called back again and it's
interesting actually they you know that
it's
seen anthony in saint athanasius his
life of saint anthony he talks about
anthony spending 20 years you know first
in the tombs and then in this ruined
fort hiding from everybody and
eventually people just break in and
force them to come out and he kind of
walks out and he says
athanasius says he was he'd been
initiated by god right so he's been
through this enormous training period
and then he came out and it was like he
was ready to teach now so he had to
teach and he had to go and do his work
in the world whether or not he wanted to
and any other number of saints from
saint cusper to saint coleman here in
ireland have the same thing they spend
their time living in caves or on islands
they try to escape they do their work
but then when they're ready they're
brought back in again
so it's almost like there's a balance
between the desert and the and this and
the town the desert there's the kingdom
really you have to get that balance
between the world and the kingdom right
even if you're
certainly not ever going to be a great
saint um
and so maybe that's i keep looking for
the challenge in the moment right the
challenge in the time what is it that
we're being offered here what's what are
we being shown
why is this happening what's the what's
the what's the challenge for us and
maybe that's what it is what's the
balance between the world and the
kingdom that you have to somehow achieve
and as you say it's a dance isn't it
it's a kind of daily dance to try and
not get consumed literally by the
machine but at the same time you know
that
you can't walk away from it entirely
wherever you go you can get a 5g signal
in the amazon now you know there's
there's no escape from it you can go to
the arctic they still you still require
a vaccine passport apparently to go to a
yes i've heard about that station so
there's no escape
um so it is that is that balance all the
time
so how
how is this because i mean i've been
following really your your sub stack and
the articles but i are you working on
any fiction right now has that has this
been kind of informing your own fiction
fiction writing well i'm not i've got a
the paperback of my novel alexandria is
coming out in uh may in britain um it's
already out in the states uh
actually that's a novel which is exactly
about all of this i i find that i've
what i do is i tend to write the same
thing in fiction and non-fiction i write
i write a novel and then i write the
same thing in non-fiction or the other
way around for some reason i can't get
the things out of my head
and so that book is a is an examination
it's set a thousand years in the future
and it's an examination exactly of of
the kind of
the battle between the body and the
machine which is what this is coming
down to this is coming down to a kind of
gnostic machine culture in which we
upload our minds and live forever
supposedly versus a kind of rooted
bodily humanity
um which is again i think you could
probably trace right back to kane you
could trace it right back to adam and
eve actually you're gonna you're gonna
thought is it is it i will be done or is
it do what that will you know those are
the kind of two streams that i keep
seeing
so that's that i mean that that's coming
out but that's a novel i wrote before
covid actually um so i have i'm not
writing anything else at the moment
apart from these essays because they're
all consuming to be honest
too too consuming sometimes i'm working
my way through
what this system is how it came about
how it's manifesting today
and then the the final part of the
series which i'm going to be starting i
suppose in a few months is
the conversation we've been having now
really how do we live through this what
what are the kind of practical responses
we can have
and it's been a really interesting
project not just the writing but the the
um the conversations with some of the
readers you know there's some really
smart people and some of them are quite
intimidating they're much cleverer than
me so which is which is great because
they tell me things i should be reading
and things i should be seeing and but
it's it's that as well as the the state
of the world has helped to sharpen
kind of how i'm seeing it but it's um
yeah but it
feels like there's a it feels like
there's an interesting watershed moment
that happened
i guess around the time of the trucker
convoy where there are certain things
that no one was allowed to say or very
few people dared say before and then all
of a sudden
public figures were starting to talk
about things that no no one was allowed
to talk about the world economic forum
and i imagine when you did in your in
your essay people came after you saying
conspiracy this conspiracy that but all
of a sudden that seems like that
watershed is
that's that's happened and so now you
know you see majin nawaz and joe rogan
talk about you find people you know
jordan peterson has been talking about
it so you see people mentioning it now
in a way that is just more realizing
wait a minute this is not
there's no there's no hidden conspiracy
they're just telling you what they're
going what they want to do and they're
showing how much power they have like
there's nothing hidden about it it's
just there yeah no it's fascinating that
again this is another one of these
political
kind of
weird things has happened when i was an
anti-globalization activist 20 years ago
you know we were all protesting against
the world economic forum and the g8 and
and the wto that was what the left did
it was what the anarchists did right of
course you do because these are the
global power structures now apparently
mentioning the same thing makes you a
right-wing conspiracy this and again you
know i read klaus schwab's book on
covert 19 which is called covid19 the
great reset it's a very boring book it's
not all
disappointingly dull actually but you
know this this is not a conspiracy
theory it's very very clear
it was on the cover of time magazine it
was they had a time magazine saying the
great reset on the cover yeah i mean
it's like an agenda it's a program these
are the most powerful guys in the world
they love global capitalism they want to
roll it out here's the plan you can like
it or lump it to be fair to klaus fab
he's very open about it he's got a
website you know
this is not doing stuff under a volcano
this is very clear these are the powers
of the world
um the people used to know that you know
the left used to know that the activists
used to know i don't know why
it's been left to the likes of joe rogan
to have to talk about it when all of the
people who used to be anti-capitalistic
suddenly decided it's fine it's a
mystery
but yeah it's it's very very open and as
you say people are now just talking
about it because you can't not talk
about it it's very clear what's going on
uh and one of the things that it's just
like it's just like it's like the tip of
an iceberg that you know klaus fab is
just a sort of useful whipping boy
for for because he's he's kind of naive
enough to put his ideas on paper and put
them out there so so everyone goes for
him as if he was a kind of ringleader
but he's just a manifestation of of of
the system that that exists and he
thinks it's a good thing you know he
thinks it'll be great once the world is
managed in this way
and this is what's gonna save the planet
and um
seems to me there ought to be discussion
about that without the conversation
being removed from the internet
and but i the
it's very it's not that to see what
happened is not that difficult in the
sense that
someone somewhere realized or maybe it
just organically appeared
that if you
made a gesture
towards
that part of the system we talked about
which is you can be whatever you want
you can self-identify you can you know
that that all identities have you know
all these marginal identities have value
if you can gesture to that
then people will give you all the
control you need on this side
and so it's a it's like a it's a weird
game so just so justin trudeau says you
know like
we we we are our only value is inclusion
right that's what he said he said our
only value is our only as canadians our
only value is inclusion and so it's like
if he does that then you can close down
people's bank accounts
yeah well it's interesting i mean i
think that the way the way i'm
understanding it is that
as you say that
there's a kind of
ideology of borderlessness that really
is about
that it appeals to a lot of people on
the left because they they think borders
are oppressive which sometimes they can
be it appeals to capitalists because
borders get in the way of the free flow
of movement and labor it appeals to
klaus schwab who's a kind of globalized
ideologue who wants a one world system
so as you say you can get a lot of
people on board by gesturing towards
uh the notion that all borders and
boundaries are bad things so there are
no borders there are no boundaries there
are no limits and once you start to say
there are no limits then you're back
into the technological system again
because the technological system
fundamentally says
we are going to use technology to
liberate you from nature including your
human nature and that's why you know the
guys in silicon valley are very very
open about their project that we're all
going to end up living forever this is
how it's going to be well the oligarchs
are on you i don't know if the rest of
us will be able to afford it but most
people yes they certainly will be um
and that again is this kind of gnostic
project of borderlessness no borders no
boundaries no limits
uh no natural limits no political limits
no cultural limits all limits are bad
all borders about all boundaries about
and that's a project that a certain type
of leftist and a certain type of
capitalist and a certain type of
political ideologue of different stripes
actually can get on board with because
it's about busting through boundaries
it's about saying
yeah we can define anything in any way
we can we can find our gender any way we
want our society we can define nature
any way we want we can define redefine
death or abolish it
um all that's left is the kind of the
will
it's the will to power any anything that
you could imagine you could do and so it
start you start to see this this this
system
being created which simultaneously tells
us there are no limits to anything and
at the same time controls us in a way
that we've never been controlled before
and it's a it's a sinister combination
yeah and liturgically you could say in
terms of actual religious
manifestation embodiment what we can we
saw during covet is the final result of
that which is the isolation of
individuals the
absolute isolation of individuals from
each other and the you know the masking
and the cutting off the social
distancing you know it ended up being in
narratively it ended up showing us what
that world looks like how this world of
of like infinite will to power in the
metaverse is basically a world of
complete self-isolation from others
related individuals and they're sitting
there there's a terrific famous
photograph i'm sure you've seen it
one of mark zuckerberg's events when
he's running the setting up his
there's this room full of all these kind
of guys with their headsets on and
zuckerberg's just walking down next to
them looking very smug and you think
there's the future everyone is utterly
isolated here utterly isolated but
theoretically all in the same place
which isn't real but they think it's
real or they they pretend that they do
and there's kind of zuckerberg the
oligarch looking very happy about this
and it is a recreation of the world in
which you're utterly isolated staring
into something that's fake
but you have an illusion of togetherness
which has replaced the real togetherness
and the new illusion of togetherness
is profitable absolutely every aspect of
it can be milked for cash everything can
be milked for money everything is
tracked everything is monitored unlike a
real community which is not profitable
at all except on a cultural and
spiritual level
if you're living in a real family in a
real community in a real place not very
much can be monetized you know not very
much can be turned into a consumer good
and sold back to you because you're just
you those are not your values
so we take everything human we destroy
it we monetize it and then we sell it
back to people as a kind of fake digital
community
and if they don't like it they can have
their bank accounts taken away
there's your system there's your system
of control
and it's uh it's the disturbing thing
about it and you know you can look at
zuckerberg's film of the metaverse for a
good example is how many people seem to
think this is just going to be great
you know there are a lot of people who
are really up for it and it's not in
some ways it doesn't have to be imposed
it has to be imposed on those at the
margins who object to it yeah but for a
lot of people it can just be sold to
them and they they seem to like it and
that's that's the most disturbing thing
to me
something happened too in terms of
narrative you can see it in the shift
between the matrix and ready player one
like the the aesthetics of the matrix as
the system that has to be resisted at
the system that has to be escaped got
replaced by ready player one which is
who controls the system that's all that
matters that is it's not that you can
try to limit its power no it's
all-encompassing it takes up all of your
attention and it it is the most powerful
controlling thing
it's just the question is who is going
to control it and the last matrix movie
which was horrible by the way but i
watched anyways because i wanted because
i had this anyway you watch these things
so that we don't have to we're pretty
yeah because i had an intuition that the
new matrix movie would be something like
pro matrix like it's pro matrix but
pretends to be rebellious nonetheless
and it it was kind of like that i'll
spoil it for everybody it doesn't matter
it ends with like it ends with neo and
trinity trinity taking over from neo and
becoming like the
the man in the relationship you could
say and then both of them
becoming heads of the matrix basically
saying they're going to steer the matrix
in the direction that they want
and i was like wow
that's that's fascinating isn't it
i've you know i was thinking to myself
i'd lead today that if they made a
version of the matrix now it would agent
smith would be the good guy you know
he'd be misunderstood and
yeah now that's very interesting because
you know the other thing i think about
endlessly is is the ring of power you
know tolkien again he keeps coming up
and
to to try and control the matrix for
good is the equivalent of taking the
ring to use it exactly isn't it you know
it's like and
what's so interesting about that is that
of course
the wise people the the people like
gandalf they know you can't even touch
the ring right
it's it's the the foolish and the
ambitious ones who think you can take
it's the humans and the twisted wizards
and you have to use the hobbit because
the hobbit the hobbit is so kind of
naive and innocent that he just you know
it's possible for him to touch this
thing but no we're in the world in which
we all think that we can take the ring
and use it for our own good or we can
control the matrix you're right and
that's that's been the shift for the
last 20 years and that actually has been
the shift perhaps on the left as well
it's certainly been the shift in the
green movement that i used to kind of
run with
you know the green movement 40 years ago
was being directed intellectually by
people like ivan ilitch and jackie law
and wendell berry you know it was a
movement of people who said look we've
got to get out of this machine and we've
got to rebuild community and have a
relationship with nature because that's
how you protect nature it's by living
with it right and and caring for it uh
it was human it was about the human
scale and that was always what the old
greens were about and the new greens are
about as many wind farms as possible as
many solar power stations as possible as
much technological control as possible
as long as you use it to create a quote
sustainable system so it's exactly the
same narrative take the ring use it for
good control the matrix don't worry
it'll be fine this time
the good guys are running the huge
control system so that's all right
and it's it's it is like an endlessly
repeating system it's a tower of babel
story again isn't it that we talked
about last time you stuck
don't worry we'll just we'll all get
together and build this thing and it'll
be fine
it'll be totally yeah it'll be totally
fine but
i mean we know the story we know that
this we know even by the very nature of
these systems that they are increasingly
fragile there is no way around it that's
what they are because they also because
even the notion of the metaverse is
if you you can understand how fragile
they are because
the identity of your your let's say your
supposedly self-willed identity in the
metaverse is nonetheless extremely
contrived within the parameters of the
metaverse your people i mean i guess
people
your embodied existence is so
um
it has all this breathing space you know
in its in its experience you have i mean
and you exp
i i'm telling you that because in your
books that that's what you also are
constantly bringing up is that these
experiences that almost even normal day
experience like drinking water or
putting on a shirt like these
experiences have an infinite complexity
in them they have a kind of infinite
richness which gets completely stunted
in the digital world by the very fact
that the parameters are limited in the
program and so
there's a sense in which
that's an image of how these systems
cannot because a human person cannot be
fully contained you just can't you
cannot contain an identity completely
it's it's impossible by definition and
so trying to do that will ultimately
lead to
fragility and and uh
a shattering at some point you cannot
it's not possible no will and that's the
hope actually you know god god is not
mocked that's that's the hope you can't
you can't contain a human you can't
contain nature you can't recreate it
however clever you think you are
and everything is it's all built on sand
i mean you can
you know these things all rely on the
power grid to operate right they all
rely on fossil fuels they'll rely on the
enormously complex
grid of civilization which is destroying
the natural world and undermining its
own kind of cohesiveness at a human
level as well
so it isn't firstly it can't be
contained you actually just literally
cannot reproduce nature as much as
as much as you think you can
and secondly it's you know it's it's
coming apart already economically
ecologically culturally it's it's
undermining itself by attempting to do
it which is why interestingly
um i think if you if you compare our
moment to say say the 60s moment right
so the 60s you've got this huge
counterculture and if you look at the
sort of the the cultural stories of
coming out of the 60s it's all about
optimism right we can it's the age of
aquarius everything's gonna be great
we're gonna smash the shackles we're
gonna get rid of the limits we're gonna
we're gonna it's gonna be free love and
etc etc didn't really work out um but
the the stories now that are coming out
even from the the supposedly counter
cultural movements are all stories of
let's see if we can get the hell out of
this collapsing system so you know what
does jeff what does jeff bezos see and
and these guys offer us elon musk they
offer us a life on another planet
because we basically ruined this one you
know don't worry we can build bubbles on
mars we'll live in them or go off and
live in space or you can live in the
metaverse we'll create another world
rather than trying to live in this one
and that's what it comes down to with
all these guys the new ideology you know
it's gone from this is the age of
aquarius we can create a utopia here
you know
to
okay that was a disaster never mind
we'll literally build another world and
live in that one you know we'll either
live on the moon under domes or we will
live in the metaverse it's almost like
we've given up on nature we've given up
on human nature we've given up on
culture we've given up on everything
human and real
and we're going to allow the likes of
mark zuckerberg or ellen musk to build
us a new
yeah a new kingdom it's a it's a twisted
religious story of
transcendence basically
and there's something i think there's
something also
about how let's say the physical world
or the embodied existence it creates it
sets up a certain amount of limits
that frames your experience in a way
that is just
it's unacceptable to a lot of these of
the ideologues and that's i think part
of the problem right because it's not
true that i mean you can pretend we're
seeing the problems with that you can
pretend that you can self
identify as anything you can do that
it's but it's gonna look very odd it
doesn't look odd in the metaverse
because you can just basically change
your avatar into whatever you want it to
be and so in the metaverse you actually
can just be whatever you want and nobody
will know that you're something else but
in but there's a disjunct in reality
which is that
this world imposes limits they're like
they impose kind of these sacred limits
to to
the possibilities of different
identities and how they interact with
each other and i think that that's
even in the technological problem uh
project itself and this kind of
fetishization of technology and pushing
the limits further there's something in
which th the notion that the you know
it's like you you want to put pork genes
in tomatoes
and it's not even that it's just you
really just want to do it to show that
you can break down the natural you know
identities and the natural things that
exist in the world it's like it's almost
like it is like a will to power but in
the in the physical world it it always
will be limited it'll it'll always be
contrived and so metaverse is the per
great salute it's the only solution in
the end to their ideology it's playing
god i mean quite literally and i i
always come back to the the the eating
of the apple it's you know what's what's
the offer here what's the offer well you
can either live according to the will of
god according to the dao according to
the way of things and you can achieve
a theosis in the end you know you can be
raised up or
you can say well you know what i think
i'll walk away from that i'll
individuate and i'll be god myself i'm
going to choose power over over
communion effectively and that's the
oldest story and
i always talk about this thing i call
the machine as a effectively it's a
machine for destroying limits that's
fundamentally what it does and
it is it is the thing that unites all
these supposedly disparate strands of
politics and economics at the moment
which is that none of these people
believe in limits and they don't think
there should be any limits and any
thought of being limit limited
is an outrage increasingly you know it's
it's crazy it's dangerous it's it's you
know whether it's limits around your
nation or whether it's limits to you or
the the length of time you can live or
as you say limits to what you can
identify yourself as
limits to what your culture can be
limits to the the amount you can exploit
nature
all of this is you know those limits
should just not be there we don't we
don't think that's fair it's a it's
almost an injustice to be limited
it might be that this is kind of the
final phase of liberalism and liberalism
being a project that tells us that
that we can we can break through limits
you know many of you know and part of
that has been beneficial for us
um but it's almost kind of metastasized
into a project that doesn't
understand where true limits are because
the
it seems to me that in a sane society
you've got a balance between limits
and
you know the need for limits and the
need for freedom and as you've said
before you know the balance between the
margin and the center and the balance
has to be there you can't have a society
that's too centralized and controlling
you can't have a society that has no
limits on anything otherwise you haven't
got a society right so you've got to
achieve that uneasy balance
and we've gone to the point
in all sorts of ways now where the the
aim of almost everything at the head of
our culture is the destruction of all
limits and all stories and all
boundaries and all borders and anything
that gets in the way of whatever we
think
is going to somehow make us fulfilled
well we don't even know what that is
right we don't know what the aim is
it is almost like a it is like a broken
technological version of a of a
religious story you know you just use
your own technological power
to effectively get to heaven and live
forever rather than
doing anything that requires you to
question anything or break it down again
yeah and the deal ends up being that
ultimately we end up serving the machine
that's the that's the secret deal it's
that's the the secret that the genie
isn't telling you is that ultimately it
really is like a bad
horror story or some old legend about
you know something some witch offering
you like a cookie offering you something
that will give you
some power but then ultimately you
become a slave of
to become a slave and i think that
that's what's going to be a battery in
the matrix don't you i mean
that's why that original story was so
good it's like hey you know what you are
you're just a battery you know and you
think you think you can live forever you
know you're actually in a pod halfway up
a tower being
being siphoned for your electric current
it's a horrible image and it's it's such
a resonant one because it's kind of true
that's
that those original films worked because
they channeled something that probably
the filmmakers didn't even know they
were doing i think that's what i spent i
think they the they made that movie and
then spend the rest of their lives
trying to kind of undo or deconstruct
their own movie i think they did because
they'd shown that was such a powerful
set of images disguised as a kind of
kick-ass kung fu movie you know it was
basically like
here is modern life this is what it is
and everybody kind of knew it so when
you saw the images presented like that
you just thought oh my god
and it's yeah as you say they can't they
can't undo it once they've done it and
there's a way in which
that you know mcluhan talked about how
we we're becoming this the the
reproductive organs of the machine like
that basically the machine needs us in
order to reproduce but one that what
i've realized is that with opposite from
what we see in the matrix we're actually
being farmed for intelligence is what
we're being farmed for so it's taking
the highest aspect of humanity
and then
somehow making it into a resource and so
we're we're there to give intelligence
to this thing we're there to make google
intelligent because
machines don't have intelligence on
their own they need to farm it out to
humans gather it up into algorithms and
then
then use it to
turn it back on us but ultimately we're
we're providing intelligence to and
we're doing it by attention it's really
religious it's like you do you want to
know how a god
was born in the old world right it's
like you
through our attention and are giving our
intelligence to this thing
then it is becoming more and more alive
and more and more salient and coming
back down on us and imposing itself
through through its paren different
parameters through its rules through its
framing of our reality so it's a it's a
very very disturbing trade that we're
participating in yeah it's like creating
an aggregator isn't it
um there's a the disturbing thing about
it is that in silicon valley there's a
lot of guys who are very conscious of
this and this is their religious
worldview
um i i talk often about this book called
what technology wants by kevin kelly i
don't know if you've read it but it's a
really good book
if you want to know how these guys are
thinking you should read that book it's
a few years old and i wrote an essay
about it a while back kevin kelly is one
of the i don't know i don't think he
worked for google but he was certainly
right in there with with the silicon
valley lads
um and kelly's
kelly's book precisely says this he says
look this system that we're creating
which he calls the technium not the
machine but it's the same thing he says
he says it's using us to create itself
so it's a really interesting book
because it's almost a it's a it's a very
sharp critique of the machine
that you might expect to say get from
someone like illog except that kelly
thinks it's good right so he finally
fundamentally is saying you know because
you get a lot of critics of technology
and then the counter critics will come
along and they'll say oh no no
technology is neutral it's just what you
do with it that counts you know you can
use it for good or use it for bad and
kelly says no that's rubbish technology
is not neutral it has an agenda it's
going in a certain direction and it's
using us to create itself and this is
going to be terrific because what we're
basically doing is building our
evolutionary replacement
okay and this is what these guys are
really up to and they they're very open
about it again it's like klaus fab
though they're not they're not hiding
anything right they genuinely believe in
a very mystical sense in a very
religious sense
that they are creating a new world with
a new consciousness in it and maybe they
are and they're trying to manifest a new
consciousness through this stuff so as
you say google is not just a thing that
helps you to find stuff that you're
interested in it's a it's a collection
mechanism that's been created very
deliberately to do that and again that
was very open
uh yeah but it's not going to be an old
it's not going to be a new consciousness
it's going to be a very very old
consciousness like a like a bad sound
like a bad like a bad uh you know
fantasy narrative where you know an old
god is buried in the ground and then you
finally unearth it and it comes back
we'll be staring
we'll be staring down the down azazel in
no time
no actually funnily enough that was sort
of sort of the plot of my novel or at
least the conceit of it as well is that
you know what you think you're raising
is not what you're raising but you are
raising something and so
on one side you've got critics of
technology like ll or wendell berry who
can see what's coming on the other side
you've got kevin kelly's in the mark
zuckerberg they can see what's coming
too but they think it's great and
they're trying to create it and then in
the middle and lots of other people who
are just going oh you know it's fine
it'll be right or i don't really like it
but i don't know what to do that's most
of us we're stuck there whereas on
these guys are deliberately creating a
very particular world and it's
manifesting
very fast i mean it's
if you if you're not disturbed by the
armed robot dogs which are already in
operation then i don't know what to say
to you you know where do you think this
is going
where do you think it's going um it's
yeah that's that's what's coming very
fast now it might even be if you want to
talk about it
kind of mystically or spiritually that
that
we can somehow sense this thing being
born around us and that's part of the
confusion of the moment yeah something
else is in control at this point
and it isn't really us anymore these
systems have outrun us you know the the
machine is much bigger than us
and to some degree it's starting to not
need us as much as we thought it did
yeah but there's a manner in which that
is technically easy to see because as
the system
rolls out and as it becomes more and
more apparent what direction is going in
order to maintain relevant you have to
compete in order to
be of those that help the system attain
its gold faster or else you're going to
lose power in the system so all the
governments are all competing about who
gets that digital id first who gets to
digital currency first all of this they
realize will will if you fall behind at
this point then you're going to be left
back in this in this thrust so it the
system itself seems to be like you said
kind of creating itself through our
desire to participate in it and our
desire to not be
on the margins of it and so it's it's
you know you could it's it's almost it
really is all like elon musk is an easy
vision of that where he he
consciously said it he kept warning
warning warning and then realized well
okay well i guess these warnings aren't
being heard so
i need to now not get left back and i'm
going to create a neural chip in your
brain that's going to that's going to
connect you directly to the matrix yeah
yeah i know that's i've never quite been
able to work him out actually i don't
know what's going on with elon musk he's
a very strange character you never know
quite quite what side is under you but
yeah in terms of what he's doing it's
it's very clear which direction it's
going in
um i mean he's his
has a very disturbing humor about it you
know starlink is very close to skynet i
mean it's basically taking the same
words and just changing them a little
like what's the difference
it's like the guys who thought
presumably either they thought it would
be funny or they have no idea what's
going on and they decided that it would
be a good idea to put your
scannable vaccine passport chip in your
right hand you know to literally put it
under the skin in your right hand which
is already happening in parts of the
world it's like okay hang on we have a
mark in our right hand through which you
need to buy and sell is this an
elaborate joke or is this something very
much worse what's happening here you
know which came first the prophecy or
the guys who thought it would be funny
to joke about the prophecy yeah does it
matter
no yeah yeah it doesn't matter it seems
but it does seem like christianity like
this is part of the story like this is
all
supposed to happen somehow like we we
don't we're not supposed to participate
in the scandal but the scandal will
happen this is going to manifest and you
know we need to be attentive as it's as
it's happening and not be naive about
what its implications are especially
for me when they here in canada it was
so when they imposed the covet passport
for church
is when then i started screaming at the
top of my lungs like okay
now
like there's no that you know i cannot i
cannot be silent about this anymore this
is now really reaching in the level that
is
that is apocalyptic so we have to we we
have to not be complicit as much as we
can in this so yeah yeah well that was
that was the same for me as it was the
vaccine passport system you know up
until that point i've been thinking okay
well
uh maybe this all makes sense i i don't
know
who who am i i'm not a virologist yeah
i'm doing what i'm told
but it was very clear that what was
happening with the passport system was
nothing to do with the science behind
the vaccines had nothing to do with
science behind the virus
and it was very much about coercion
and the fact that
as i say everything kind of clicked into
place you had the state you had the
corporations you had the media and they
were all they were all going down the
same track
without any dissent and it was extremely
disturbing and you didn't have to know
exactly what was going on
to scream at the top of your voice and
say this is wrong but then of course as
soon as you did you were called a crazy
conspiracy theorist who thought the
lizards were running everything
but it's um again it's that sense of you
you just know you just know there is
something very bad happening here where
this kind of stuff is just being rolled
out
and we're okay with it
and it continues to be rolled out as you
say the digital currencies are coming
the global digital ids are coming the
ability to shut people's bank accounts
down is already here but it will get
much easier when that stuff happens
and yeah at this point if you haven't
seen what's unrolling you need to wake
up very quickly and then work out what
you're going to do about it because
it's not going to be as it's supposed to
be a system of total control i don't
think it will be because i don't think
it will work and i don't think it can
last
it's too ambitious it's not going to be
able to be rolled out around the world
but it's going to be rolled out far
enough
that it could do um
it's going to do tyrannical things and
and the disturbing the really
frightening possibility is that some of
the
things they're trying to create in
silicon valley will work you know some
of these artificial intelligences will
come about the giant
system which barely needs any human
interaction at all
we'll be able to will be able to work
and that's that's the name of the game
that's very that's very much on the
table
so yeah you need to think hard about
whether your option is
benedict or anthony or or anything else
you know
i don't know but yeah that's that's
where we are i think yeah i'm going for
the king david ronan option right now
yeah yeah we need you need a list of
different options that people can
contribute to you know
i think it's that's the way forward yeah
but there's an interesting like i've
been playing with the image of the ronin
like there's this interesting story in
japan that called the 47 ronin about
a master that was wrongfully
uh let's say
lost his honor wrongfully and the all
these ronins spend 50 years or like i
don't know years and years preparing for
their revenge but in doing so some of
them have to fall into all these states
that look completely
disloot you know they they someone
becomes like you know not sure if he's
really a drunk or he's pretending to be
drunk but like there's this fall into
these states of hiding and of uh and of
trickery let's say so i think that at
some point that's the this is the
situation we have to be wise we have to
be wise like serpents so
yeah and i think we can't afford to be
respectable either you know i mean
that's the other thing i always come
back to this i mean christ was not
respectable
none of his disciples were respectable
saint anthony was not respectable saint
francis was not respectable um
you you know you are you if you can't
you can't be conformed to the world
because this is where the world is going
consciously or unconsciously so you have
to be prepared to be
well all the things that christ told you
you were going to be right rejected and
humiliated and attacked and all the rest
of it not for the sake of it just
because you're being a contrarian but
you know you have to that's the really
hard but you know you have to say if i'm
going to walk in the direction i need to
walk in
i'm going to be metaphorically wearing
rags
or maybe actually wearing rags so
there's a lot of renunciation i think
that has to come somehow
again that'll be different for different
people but maybe that's the hardest bit
for those of us who probably come from
sort of comfortable countries you know
there's a renunciation involved whether
it's reputational or physical or
material or whatever it is
you know there's um and that's what the
interesting people always do you know
the marginal people who can
bring the wisdom back into the center
you know the fools for christ this is
what we're we're not we're all going to
be called to doing the same thing but
there's something that nags away at me
about the need to
to renounce and to walk away in some way
before you can
see what the kind of the next stage of
the path is so that's a really
interesting question to
kind of prey on actually to think you
know what's the what's the renunciation
here where do i walk which way do i go
so
listen i think this is a good place to
to to end thanks for thanks for that bit
of wisdom and uh everybody you need to
subscribe to paul's uh sub stack because
it's it's just great it's a it's a
wonderful place to meditate and to think
about what's going on in a way that is
is insightful but also
um
let's say not not political like not not
political in the basis sense right not
not uh not one-sided but really
thoughtful so thanks for all the work
you're doing and uh you know i'm really
looking forward paul and i are
collaborating together on the
on a project called the saint basil's i
forget saint basil school of of of of
writing yeah
and uh and so i'm looking forward to
doing that as well where one of the
solutions to this problem is also to
help people understand true beauty and
uh tell better stories make better
images you know and be able to
participate in in the world through
beauty because that
it's not a small thing it actually
creates patterns for imitation for other
people it sends out ripples into the
world when you participate in beauty so
so everybody look forward for that as
well so paul thanks for your time right
thank you joseph as you know the
symbolic world is not just a bunch of
videos on youtube we are also a podcast
which you can find on your uh usual
podcast platform but we also have a
website with a blog and several very
interesting articles by very intelligent
people that have been thinking about
symbolism on all kinds of subjects we
also have a clips channel a facebook
group you know there's a whole lot of
ways that you can get more involved in
the exploration and the discussion of
symbolism don't forget that my brother
matsuya wrote a book called the language
of creation which is a very powerful
synthesis of a lot of the ideas that
explore and so please go ahead and
explore this world you can also
participate by you know buying things
that i've designed t-shirts with
different designs on them and you can
also support this podcast and these
videos through paypal or through patreon
everybody who supports me has access to
an extra video a month and there are
also all kinds of other goodies and
tiers that you can get involved with so
everybody thank you again and thank you
for your support